so this is a very very special sample of
lutetium again from the bottom end of
the periodic table the lanthanides and
you can see it's a really quite
beautiful metallic foil here so lutetium
is the last of the 4f lanthanide series
and it's also used for dating and
meteorites and it's a very small sample
it weighs just a few milligrams but it's
a very very nice sample stirred under an
inert atmosphere so that we can control
the chemistry so there's full of
unreacted argon so we can't form the
oxide lutetium although it might not be
obvious to you it's named after a
european capital city lutetium is also
used in Reggio nucleotide treatment for
cancers so it's got a very useful role
and in fact it's named after Paris
because Leticia was the Roman name for
Paris when it was a Roman city and
therefore lutetium is one of the few
elements that is named after a city
there's some of the other rare earths
are named after cities in Sweden but
lutetium is the one that is perhaps most
easily recognizable at least by people
like me who had to be learn Latin when
we were children like thulium a is very
expensive so we save it for special
occasions when we know something will
absolutely work for Scheuer then we'll
we'll try it with lutetium